[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nba competition committee will
reportedly look into the way certain
shooters initiate contact and draw fouls
with
unnatural movements aka the reggie
miller rule
james harden and trey young have uh
made a a living out of doing this reg is
the godfather of this he joins us now
we're gonna call it the reggie miller
rule what do you think this is getting
ridiculous
i'm serious i mean i got penalized i
shouldn't say
i but they put the rule in about the leg
kick
which to this day i still believe is a
good
move and a good shot but it's unnatural
though you're kicking your leg out to
draw
i'm not kicking i'm just creating
space that's all this is my
space so look okay explain this though
what
they're focusing this rule on james
harden and trey young right
and we've been hearing this year about
those two players and i guess you can
probably throw yana's in there as well
offensive players seeking out
contact on drives on those floaters
and initiating the contact and getting
the call
it is i think it's going to be so hard
to monitor for these officials they
already got enough on their plate
now they've got to figure out in a split
second
at times without the help of replay
who's initiating the contact
they wanted scoring up so what they're
really doing is penalizing
the shooter and the scorer in this
instance so
i'm a little surprised at that because
freedom of movement this is what they've
always wanted
so this is gonna to me kind of hurt some
of the scores because
as a natural-born scorer as i won
was you do seek out contact i felt
i played better and i shot better when i
knew
where the defender was when i could feel
him it was a much harder shot for me if
i was wide open
as opposed to someone closing to me
closing on me or being right on my body
i felt that was a little bit easier for
me to get the ball off and score
but it feels like trey young and james
harden there's a gimmick about
them drawing their contact
i'm more surprised they haven't talked
about like the traveling and the step
backs and the side steps to me that's
more infuriating than seeking out
contact but
i i kind of get it a little bit
less free throws maybe faster games
maybe that's what the nba is trying to
do here
i don't know
again you're you're adding and piling on
these officials
to make split second decisions
in big time moments of playoff games or
for next year i mean i i think they're
overloaded already the officials and now
you're telling them they got to be able
to
um differentiate between who's making
the contact
yeah good luck with that do you
think that there were referees that
didn't like you
like truly didn't like you
i wouldn't say didn't like me but there
were certainly some officials
i felt at times i
had a bias um
i wouldn't say didn't like i mean that's
a strong word i felt like i could
communicate with most officials there
were some officials that you just
couldn't
say anything to it was a quick t and
you're kind of muted for the rest of the
game
but i felt i had a pretty good
relationship with most officials
though i did talk a lot to them and
complain a lot to them
it's how you go about it and does
complaining work reg
no it doesn't but it sure made me feel
better
no it doesn't it isn't a date no it
doesn't
but what you're trying to do and what i
was trying to do you're always trying to
plant
a little bit of seed because if it's a
close game
and the game is in the balance you want
all that talking you did through three
and a half
quarters to matter in the last two
minutes of a close game
that's probably the only reason why i
talked so much
was trying to plant a seed reg will be
on the call for the eastern conference
finals
uh who do you expect to be in the
eastern conference finals
well last week we talked about this was
going to be a sweep by brooklyn they
were looking great and
i keep telling people it's great to have
the best talent in the world it's great
to be well coached
but to win a championship theodore
you've got to have a lot of luck on your
team
you think about kobe's and shaq's the
repeat with the lakers you think about
mj and scotty and back to back the
repeats
a lot of were they talented absolutely
were they well coached absolutely but
you've got to have a lot of luck
can you even remember when mj even
thought about this in the game because
of an injury when he was
i can't remember if he ever did miss a
game
and it wasn't like he was just shooting
jump shots i mean he was driving
punishing people and no twisted ankles
no
knee issues a lot of luck goes into
winning championships and we're
the healthiest team is going to win win
this year's championship
who's going to be standing at the end i
mean it's it's unfortunate injuries are
a part of the game
you just don't want them at this time of
the year which we're seeing right now
yeah and harden's status he's upgraded
to doubtful
for tonight yeah yeah he's not going to
play now it's on kevin durant
and and he's had the benefit of these
super teams recently
now it's back to all right okay let's
see
let's see what you can do let's see go
out there
let's see you win a a big game i will
say this
um if there's any one player who could
deliver a huge game in a moment like
this
it's kevin durant and i will say this
role players play better at home i
expect brooklyn and
some of these guys that normally don't
get the limelight because it's
kyrie or james harden along with kd
they'll shoot
better they'll play harder that uh
new york crowd will kind of energize
them a little bit
it's you know i'm not going out on a
limb here who wins tonight
to me wins the series between milwaukee
and brooklyn
if i'm brooklyn all i'm saying is look
let's just win our home games we win our
home games
we advance to the conference finals
but this is milwaukee's best chance this
will may be their only chance because if
it goes seven games
i can't see them winning back in
brooklyn yeah this is the chance for
milwaukee to win the series
they've got to win tonight with two
superstars down for the nets
and just kd it's got to be all our chips
in the center of the table for milwaukee
they
they must win tonight to win this series
is it a bigger game for durant or a
bigger game for the greek freak because
he doesn't have any excuses here i
i agree um i think there's built-in
excuses for
kd because he doesn't have kyrie in
harden
but to be it's the only game tonight
all eyes will be on this matchup and
let's face it
milwaukee has come up short the last two
years they've had the best record the
last two years
and they've fallen short and greek has
not played up to
mvp expectations by winning back-to-back
mvps
come play off he has disappeared he had
a great game four
but you're right why is he taking those
threes
what's that why is the greek freak
taking those threes i have no idea like
and i want him to take they're daring
him
they're daring him they're baiting him
into it
but that's a recipe for disaster
i i just don't get it i really don't get
it
yeah like i don't want him going to the
hoop if i'm if i'm brooklyn i
if you stay on the perimeter that means
you can't rebound and you're not a good
shooter
so go ahead take those shots there
and here's the thing it's not only the
threes i'd almost bait them into
long twos too if you're gonna settle
yeah and you're not gonna put pressure
on blake griffin or
any of our interior bigs
i'll i'll settle for that i'll win
that's a win if you're steve nash in
brooklyn
he's reggie miller the hall of famer
turner sports nba analyst he'll be on
the call for the eastern conference
finals chris paul getting a lot of love
after
uh the sweep and uh i was talking to
your buddy
mark jackson yesterday on where's chris
paul on the all-time
point guard list and he had chris paul
up there pretty high um i i like chris
but uh is it asking too much
that he hasn't won and i'm not talking
about an nba title
i mean he hadn't even had an appearance
there
but like getting to the uh western
conference finals i don't know
i this is this will be his second
appearance
in the western conference finals
throughout his 13 or 14
year career um and he's played on good
teams
he played i will if chris ends up
winning a
championship not this year or any year
in my opinion he moves into the top five
right now he's not in
my top five top
seven eight right now okay so it's magic
magic magic isaiah
steph we're considering steph a point
guard staff
stockton maybe jay kidd
okay that would probably be my that
would probably be my five
now if he wins a championship
i think he would bump stockton out of my
top five
wow if he was to win a championship
if he doesn't win a championship he
would probably be six or seven
you still got oscar out there you still
have gary payton out there
jerry west is he considered a point
guard he's in that mix and that
he was a shooting guard but i mean
people are going to say that about steph
as well but steph is classified as a
point guard
yeah but he's only one allen iverson
shooting guard
no he's a point guard are we putting ai
as a point guard or a shooting guard no
he's a point guard he's a scorer he's
not a shooting guard
i think eric snow was the point guard on
that team
okay okay what is lebron
he's a point guard yes he is so is the
point
is he the greatest point guard of all
time no matt
no one will ever trump magic johnson as
the best point guard
ever well wait a minute we got lebron as
the second best player of all time reg
so he's the second best player of all
time but he's not the best point guard
no he's not the best point
i'm picking you up full court
[Laughter]
yes i'm finding a way to get around you
because lebron's a point guard he's a
point forward
so was scottie scotty pippin was a point
forward
so who are you taking scotty or lebron
lebron
okay all right yeah but
all right so lebron's the second best
point guard of all time
[Laughter]
yes he is i guess you gotta put lebron
he's gonna end up top five and assist
isaiah steph no order
magic isaiah step those three are
guaranteed
those three are guaranteed there's two
spots that will always be up for debate
all right let's go to the stockton and
jk if you couldn't play with magic let
me take magic out of this the point
guard you would want to play with
current or past
either isaiah or
jason kidd for my skill set
for my skill set the one of those two
but
did you hate isaiah oh man well
it's that central division couldn't
stand him just like mj okay
you would be smiling all in your face
acting like your brand and stuff
taking the biggest cheap shots ever
and one of the toughest point guards i
love me some z
former coach coach me yeah but
sneaky nasty sneaky sneaky
does he know people don't like him
i don't think he cares really i don't
think he's
like bill and beard didn't care isaiah i
think
cared remember the whole thing with you
know what they were going to
freeze out jordan and like that bothered
isaiah
well they weren't it wasn't wrong
[Laughter]
it was true
did you so you knew were you all started
i was not on that all-star team but
rumors haven't
would you have frozen out jordan no
if you were on on if isaiah said we're
we're not going to throw in the ball
i don't know how you can freeze out i
don't know how you can freeze no you
just act like he's not
open come on man
do you think it's true though that he
froze out mike
um i think there was a little
judging from the last dance it's not
friendly
that's not friendly at all certainly
from michael's perspective
i'm rolling with z z
wait if i said you could have zeke or
mike
for my skill set like to play with yeah
i'm not rolling with either one of them
look i've got built i got built up
issues with both okay i can't roll with
either
how about steve nash you can play with
steve oh i could play with steve
yeah that's a steve nash's
top eight right he's got to be in that
category certainly top ten
the amazing thing is the phoenix suns
had jake hid kevin johnson and steve
nash at the same time
yes wow i mean wow
and kj was the starter right so the the
the backup those are the hall of famers
with jay kidd and uh steve nash i don't
think kj is a hall of famer is he
no but for those of you who have never
seen kevin johnson
i mean that's who those two dudes
learned from
was kevin johnson yeah one of the best
pick-and-roll players maybe
ever maybe ever he was
athletic man oh he was good he was oh by
the way
he and i we go back to our rivalry
between ucla and cal
so we were the same draft look i've
i've had a lot of time seeing kevin
johnson so
i got you uh playing 80 games
or more in a season 10 times
durant harden and kyrie have played 80
or more games in a season
seven times combined
would you would you have load management
now though
you have to now i mean that's like but
but travel's better nutrition is better
like everything is better now
it could have helped nash with his back
could have helped larry bird
maybe with load management there um does
it make sense to play
80 games in a season
if you love the game yeah theodore i
mean i love the game
i loved playing i love performing
looking back on my career
and someone told me this that i played
in 90 96
of my games i played over 1300 games
there's something about lacing them up
each and every day
now that i look back could i have taken
a game or two off
certainly but i always felt there was
some
fan kid mom dad
that was saving up their piggy bank to
come watch the indiana pacers play
either at home or on the road and they
heard about this guy named rachel miller
who talked a lot of trash and shot 35
40 footers this was going to be their
one opportunity to see
i didn't know who they were but i felt
it was an obligation to play
that was my mentality of playing
nobody thinks that now
it's not the money yeah i know but i
think that you know
that you're going to be able to get into
another contract if
if you limit your your games you get
ready for the postseason
and like you know kawhi that knee is
going to be an issue i don't know how
serious that knee is
if it's just arthritic and it's going to
be there you know the rest of his life
but he might be playing himself into one
more contract because of load management
here
and i i understand it i don't like it
but i do understand where this is a
business everybody's expendable and
these
athletes are trying to stay as long as
they can
and you've got to maximize what your
body will deliver and i get it
and i understand it these are
billionaires talking to millionaires
and i totally get it
i get it because you only have one body
you only have one career and you only
have
a a certain window to make as much
money as you can and that's why you see
certain guys take off during the regular
season
but to me it's kind of catching up to
them come playoff time because their
body is not used to all the pounding
come playoff time and just being in
shape reg will be on the call for the
eastern conference finals uh
great to talk to you again reg we'll
talk to you soon theodore you're the
best
love my danettes love y'all we'll come
back with phone calls after this